[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا
في منظومه الامريكيه المزمعي تسليمها لكيف
كهدف المشروع
اسرائيل
على الحدود السوريه العراقيه قبل اسابيع
والعالم يترقب والطرف الثاني لانهاء
المونديال موقعه ساخنه بين المغرب مفاجاه
البطوله وفرنسا
لليوم الثاني الشلل يضرب بريطانيا با
اضرابات عمال القطارات وانضمام قطاع
التمريض
اذا المشاهدين سنبدا من موسكو هدد المتحدث
باسم الكريم البحث
وكان مسؤولون في البنتاجون اثروا الى ان
الولايات المتحده سترسل نظام باتريوت
للدفاع الجوي الى اوكرانيا المسؤولون
اكدوا ان قرار ارسال نظام باتريوت
الصاروقي الى اوكرانيا قد يتم الاعلان عنه
هذا الاسبوع وفي هذا الاطار نقلت وكاله
رويترز عن مسؤولين بالاداره الامريكيه
قولهم ان الاعلان عن القرار قد ياتي في
وقت مبكر من يوم الخميس المقبل لكنه ينتظر
موافقه رسميه من وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن
[موسيقى]
والمزيد معنى من موسكو الدبلوماسيه السابق
اهلا بك
بالحديث عن هذه المنظومه والتي تحتاج الى
موافقه من وزاره الدفاع هل تعتقد انه
التهديد الروسي هذا باستهدافها ربما سيدفع
الولايات المتحده للتراجع لان البعض يقول
بانه الولايات المتحده اتخذت القرار
والقضيه قضيه وقت وكميه فقط
لا شك هذا مشكله تزويد لجيش اكرهيني
ببطريق سلاح الدفاع الجوي هو له الطبع
الاعلامي اكثر من ما هو من عوامل
انه مثل هذه مجموعات الصاروخيه باتريوت 3
مجموعات الصاروخيه تستطيع ان
تقاتلوا في كل انواع السلاح
الجويرات مثيره على
المنخفف او او صواريخ سريعه او مدفعيه
لذلك
كل مجموعه صاروخيه الروسيه تضاف اليه عده
متراب
انت تقول انه روسيا قادره على التعاطي مع
مثل هذا النوع من السلاح ولكن ذكرت نقطه
انه هي همم هو اعلان دعائي او اعلامي اذا
كان الوضع كذلك واذا كانت روسيا قادره على
الطاعات معها لماذا تخرج بهذا التهديد
على تلك وسائل الاعلاميه همم بنفس الطريقه
كذلك طب يعني
التبادل همم تحديدات هذا لاشياء كان في
هذه الظروف عندما الحرب الكبيره فيه
يعني التبادل كل الاتهامات وكل التهديدات
من احد اساليب همم
بهذا الاطار عندما تتحدث انه روسيا قادره
على الطاعات مع هذه الاسلحه وعندما تقول
بان استهدافها هو استهداف مشروع نتحدث عن
عمليه نقلها ام انه لا نتحدث عن طريقه
دفاعيه ليس الا
طبعا عايز الصواريخ ممكن ان يستعمله جده
التغيرات الروسيه ضد هليكوبترات ولكن على
علوم
ليست هذا هدف الرئيسي لانه ليست الدفاع
الجوي بحاجه اليوم جيش كريمي روشه تهاجم
اوكرانيا
الروسيه دمر الكهرباء
التي ذكرتها بانه يستهدفها ولكن عندي قال
همم هل عندما تتحدث الولايات المتحده عن
مثل هذه الخطوه او عذرا روسيا همم ترفع
مثل هذه التهديدات متى يمكن القول بانها
تهدد ليس اوكرانيا فقط ولكن الولايات
المتحده باعتبارها شريك مباشر الان على
الارض مع اوكرانيا
يعني شو هو الخط الاحمر الفاصل لتقول
روسيا انه الان الولايات المتحده اصبحت
فاعل على الارض باتريك او غيره
سلاح همم قوي همم
روسي امريكي
حوار
الروسيه اللي همم اذاعه اسرائيليه همم
اوكرانيه وهو قال بهذه التشريح انه ثابت
الجيش الاسرائيلي لذلك بهذا الشكل او هذا
همم دول غربيه
وهو متحالفه معهم
رقعه المواجهه ستتسع او لا من موسكو
الدبلوماسي السابق فيكسلاف متزوج شكرا
جزيلا لك
ولا تطورات الميدانيه قالت اداره مدينه
اداريين في العاصمه الاوكرانيه تتضرر في
هجوم بطائرات بدون طيار ايرانيه الصنع
مضيفه انه لا توجد حتى الان معلومات عن
اصابات او حتى وفيات محتمله وقد دعى حاكم
منطقه كيف اولكسي كلبه دع السكان للبقاء
في الملاجئ بعد الغارات الروسيه والتي
استهدفت العاصمه هذا الصباح بثلاثه عشر
مسيره وفق ما افاده مراسل العربيه الرئيس
قال اوكراني من جانبه اعلن ان الدفاعات
اسقطت جميع المسايرات الايرانيه التي
هاجمت كيف وهي من نوع شاهد بحسب تعبير
دنيا
ب 13
للمعلومات الاوليه تم اسقاط جميع المسيرات
بواسطه انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه انا
فخور بذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ان بلادها فرضت عقوبات على ايران لتزويدها
روسيا بطائرات مسيره
جاسم
روسيا وايضا بلا روسيا منورات عسكريه
بالدبابات في الداخل البيلاروسي تتضمن
المناورات التدريب على نصف الجسور والسكك
الحديديه والمباني السكنيه وحتى المطارات
ما يسمح للقوات بالتحرك بسرعه اكبر كانت
اوكرانيا اعرضت عن مخاوفها من ان تشون
روسيا هجمات عليها عبر الاراضي البلار
روسيه بسبب تدريبات العسكريه التي تجريها
منسك مع موسكو
عشيه طقمه اوروبيه تجري غدا قالت المفوضيه
الاوروبيه قالت ان اسعار واردات الطاقه
الاوروبيه ستظل مرتفعه من جهته قال
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان روسيا تستهدف بشكل
ممنهج البنا التحتيه في اوكرانيا وعلى
راسها الطاقه اشار الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
ان هناك اجماع بين الاعضاء حول حزمه
العقوبات التاسعه ضد روسيا
واكد الان في خبر اخر رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي افيفكو خافي استهدافه قافله
اسلحه ايرانيه على حدود سوريا والعراق قبل
اسابيع كما قال انه جرى التشويش تماما على
مشروع ايران وضع المئات من الصواريخ ارض
جو في سوريا وايضا في لبنان اشار الى ان
هناك رؤيه ايرانيه كانت تصبوا الى انشاء
حزب الله جديد في جنوب هضبه الجولان هذه
الرؤيه كانت تتمثل بمئات الصواريخ عشرات
الالاف من الميليشيات ايضا خافي اكد ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي منع حوالي 400 في العام
الحالي بمساعده جهاز المخابرات العامه
وايضا حرس الحدود
يخنه الولد الهجوم على قافله الشاحنات قبل
اسابيع قليله على الحدود السوريه العراقيه
نفذته اسرائيل لم نكن نعرف قبل اسابيع
قليله عن عبور القافله السوريه من العراق
الى سوريا جاري التشويش تماما على مشروع
ايران بوضع المئات من صواريخ ارض جو في
سوريا ولبنان الجيش الاسرائيلي منع نحو
400 عمليه في العام الحالي في بعض الحالات
كان يتم اطلاق اكثر من 30 الى 40 صاروخا
وفي احدى الغارات تم اطلاق سبعين صاروخ
لاتجاه طائراتنا
المزيد معنا من القاهره محمد مجاهد الزيات
مستشار المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك سيد محمد اسمحلي ان
ابدا بهذه التصريحات عاده اسرائيل تضرب
الكل يعرف انها ضربت ولكنها لا تعترف
لماذا هذه المره بهذه الحادثه تحديدا وهذا
الاستهداف تجاهر بما قامت به
اعترفت ببعضها عندما كانت الضربات قويه
يعني مؤثره هذه المره هو استعراض لرئيس
الاركان بعد يعني اثبات قدره الجيش
الاسرائيلي على التعامل مع ايران واثبات
ان ايران تهدد الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
هناك حوار يجري ما بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في هذا التوقيت حول
ضروره توجيه ضربه الى ايران لاجهاض
البرنامج النووي التي توقفت من محادثات
الخاصه به الضربه التي تمت على الشحنات
الاسلحه التي تعبر ليست الاولى يعني هناك
12 ضربه تقريبا خلال شهرين الماضيين قامت
بها القوات الاسرائيليه على مواقع تابعه
لايران هناك تمضع عسكري ايراني في منطقه
الحدود
السوريه العراقيه
دير الزور يعني بمعنى اخر هذا التصريح
ياتي
رساله للولايات المتحده وكيف له ان يؤثر
على العلاقات خاصه في ظل التطورات الاخيره
في الداخل الاسرائيلي والحكومه التي يرى
بانها تستفز الولايات المتحده
ولا اعتقد انها سوف تستفز هذه الامور
تتكرر من الحكومات الاسرائيليه ويحسن
توافق فيما بعد بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبينها لكن القضيه هنا هي
القضيه قتل بالملف الايراني بالتحديد هناك
تغير في الموقف الامريكي من التعامل مع
ايران هناك عقوبات تفرض كل يوم او كل فتره
على ايران ولك حزم من هذه العقوبات تتم
معنى ذلك ان اتفاق النووي الذي كان يدفع
الموقف الامريكي الى التهاد مع الحكومه
الايرانيه يتراجع وبالتالي يقترب الموقف
الامريكي فيما يتعلق بالتعامل مع ايران من
الموقف الاسرائيلي ولذلك اسرائيل تحاول ان
تثبت ان هناك خطرا بجودا بالنسبه لها
بتمركز ايران في سوريا وتعيد الحديث عن
ضربه تمت منذ عده اسابيح
الهدف النهائي هذا مواجهه مباشره بمعنى
اخر هي تبحث عن ضوء اخضر ااه امريكي لكي
تقوم بعمليات ابعد مما يحدث هنا تريد
السلاح من الولايات المتحده والدعم اما
ماذا
هي تحصل على الدعم وتحصل على السلاح لكن
ان تقوم بضربه همم مباشره منفرده او
بمساعده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا
اعتقد ان ذلك المطروحا والمطروح هو تخريب
البرنامج النووي الايراني من خلال عمليات
استخباريه وضرب مواقع بالنسبه لها واجهاض
الوجود العسكري في الدوائر المحيطه
باسرائيل سواء في سوريا او في حدود
العراقيه او في لبنان بما ي- يعني يشل
القدرات الايرانيه ساعه المواجهه عن ان
تؤثر بصوره كبيره على الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي
محمد لطالما قالت الولايات المتحده صراحه
مع كل الادارات التي مرت انه ايران تشكل
خطر ان كان على المنطقه وتحديدا على
اسرائيل يقال انه لم تقم اسرائيل باي
عمليه ان كانت في البحر او على الارض الا
بضوء اخضر امريكي وبالتالي الغزل هذا مع
الولايات المتحده بحسب تصريحك بانها توجه
رساله للولايات المتحده ما مرضه
يعني هو النهارده في علامات غريبه جدا
يعني طائرات المسيره التي تقع الايرانيه
التي تستخدم في ضرب اوكرانيا اكتشف او
اعترفت مصادر امريكيه واوروبيه بان قطعه
منها جاءت من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومن كندا في ظل التوقيت الذي تفرض
العقوبات على ايران في نفس الوقت
الاسرائيل تحاول ان تضغط بكل الامكانيات
على الحكومه الامريكيه لممارسه مزيد من
الضغوط لاجهاض المحاوله الايرانيه للوصول
الى العتبه النوويه بالدرجه الاولى وتضخم
من الخطر الايراني العسكري في المناطق
المحيطه بها وبالتالي تبحث عن نماذج يمكن
ان تتعامل معها بالدوائر صنع القرار في
امريكا على هذا الاساس لقبول الحكومه
للنقل الموضوع من استياء امريكا او من قلق
امريكي من
نيه الحكومه القادمه وتاثيرها على التوازن
القائم في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الى زياده
الحديث عن الخطر الايراني الذي يحيط
بالمنطقه باسرائيل حد بالفعل هناك خطر
ايراني بهذا الحجم باختصار طبعا همم وخاصه
انه في ضغطات بالداخل الايراني يقال بانها
غير قادره على دعم ذراعها في هذا التوقيت
في سوريا بالتحديد وفي اليمن للتمويل
الذاتي لهذه الميليشيات والعدم الحاجه الى
التمويل الايراني فيما يتعلق بالحضور
العسكري لا يعتقد ان هناك تراجع عن
ايرانيه عن زياده التموضع والعسكري في
سوريا ده هدف استراتيجي ونقطه ارتكاز
اساسيه والانتقال من التمركز في لبنان الى
مناطق على الحدود السوريه حتى تجنب لبنان
عمليه التدمير دخول في عمليه سياسيه معقده
هناك مركز ايراني يستقل عن سيطره الحكومه
السوريه في بعض المواقع وتستغل المواقع
وقواعد عسكريه موجوده في مناطق محيطه
بالوجود الامريكي في شرق سوريا بالتحديد
نعم طيب من القاهره محمد مجاهد الزيات
مستشار المركز المصري للفكر والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا جزيلا لك
5 ولكن بعد قليل
محاكم طهران تسجنوا 400 متظاهر ولاعب كره
قدم ايراني على ابواب الاعدام بسبب الدعم
الاحتجاجات
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل في ملف
الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث يصوت المجلس
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي التابع للامم
المتحده على مشروع قرار لطرد ايران من
لجنه وضع المراه طبعا التابع لهيئه الامم
المتحده مشروع القرار تقدمت به الولايات
المتحده بسبب وما قالت بانها سياسات ايران
التي تتعارض مع حقوق النساء الا انه من
المتوقع ان تمتنع عده دول عن التصويت قالت
ايران في رساله للمجلس ان التصويت لا يكون
هنا مرحبا به
هذا وتواصل السلطات معاقبه المحتاجين
انزلت احكام بالسجن يصل بعضها الى 10
سنوات على 400 محتاج في العاصمه طهران
لمشاركه في الاحتجاجات المناهضه للنظام
قال رئيس قضاه محافظه طهران انه حكم على
160 شخص بالسجن لمده تتراوح بين خمس عشر
سنوات على 80 شخص بالسجن من سنتين الى خمس
سنوات وعلى 160 شخصا لمده تصل الى عامين
وقد اعربت النقابه الدوليه للاعبي كره
القدم المحترفين في في
صدمه عن صدمتها لمواجهه لاعب كره القدم
الايراني امير ناصر ازادان البالغ من
العمر 26 عاما خطر صدور حكم بالاعدام بحقه
لاسباب متصله بالتظاهرات التي تشهدها
ايران منذ ثلاثه اشهر اعلنت النقابه في
حسابه على تويتر
بان لاعب كره القدم المحترف امير ناصر
ازاداني وجهه خطر الاعدام بعد ما شارك في
حمله للدفاع عن حقوق النساء والحريات
الاساسيه في بلاده
وقد تزايدت الجهود الدوليه لمنع تنفيذ
احكام الاعدام بحق المتظاهرين تزامنا مع
زياده اصدار السلطات الايرانيه هذه
الاحكام واحتمال التنفيذ الوشيك لبعضها
[موسيقى]
مزيد معنا من بيروت الدكتور احمد عجاج
استاذ القانون الدولي والباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه اهلا بالدكتور احمد بدايه تقييمك
لردود الفعل الغربيه فيما يتعلق بما يحدث
في الداخل الايراني والى اي حد هي قادره
على التاثير
اولا اهلا بك وبالمشاهدين الكرام طبعا
الرد الغربي معروف هناك اشتياق كبير من
الممارسات التي تقوم بها السلطات
الايرانيه لسبب بسيط واحد وهي ان القيم
الغربيه تعارض تماما ما تقوم به السلطات
الايرانيه ولذلك نرى هذا الضغط
الان على ايران من اجل حبتها على تغيير
المسار لكن المشكله تكمن ان هذا الضغط
الاخلاقي لن يلقى تجاوبا داخل ايران لان
ايران تعيش ازمه حقيقيه الان هناك جيل
جديد نشا بعد 43 عاما يريد ان يغير
القناعات التي عاش عليه يعني اباؤه ويريد
الانفتاح ويريد ان يعيش حياته ويوجد نظام
يمنعه من ذلك هيدروجيه واضحه وهذا التناقد
هو الذي يحمل السلطات الايرانيه على
اعتماد حلين هي تدرك انه اذا استطاعت ان
تستجيب لهذه المطالبه معناها ان النظام
الايراني
الامراض واذا لم تستجيب فان القمح
والوسيله الوحيده لذلك
فيها وقال هو ايران عندما تتحرك على الارض
بهذه الطريقه هل هي تتحدى الغرب ولا فقط
التعاطي مع المحتاجين لا يتم الا من خلال
هذه الطريقه بحسب قناعاتها
هي يعني ليس لديها الا هذا الاسلوب لانها
اذا تراخت مع المحتاجين واجتمعت اليههم
فان مطالبهم ستزداد وهذا ما يعرفه الامام
الخامنئي هو يقول ان سبب يعني اجريت
مقابله معه منذ زمن همم عندما تولى السلطه
وقال ان السبب في نجاح الثوره الايرانيه
ان الشاه ضعيف امام المتظاهرين وكنا بصدد
يعني وقف المظاهرات وعندما شعرنا بضعفه
زدنا الضغط عليه لذلك هو يدرك انه اذا
تراجع قليلا امام متظاهرين بان سبحه
المطالب ستتكرر وهو ما لا يريده ويصبح
بذلك ضعيفا امام الغرب وكل ما قام شعبه
يضعه امام الغرب امام العالم وهل من اليات
قانونيه دونيه يمكن لها ان تفرض قرار على
ايران او لا ما فيها
لا يوجد يعني ما يوجد ما يمكن للغرب ان
يفعله في هذه اللحظه هو مساعده المتظاهرين
تامين يعني الاخبار الثنائيه ليمارس يعني
عمليات التواصل الاجتماعي دعمهم معنويا
كما نرى الان في الامم المتحده الضغط
معنويا شد العصب الدولي ضد ايران لان
ايران تخضع كما نعرف لعقوبات كبيره جدا
يعني وبالتالي اي ضغوط همم اخرى لن تغير
مسار النظام لان النظام يشعر ان هذه نقطه
محوريه في حياته اما ان ينتصر واما ان
يخسر السلطه يعني هذه القضيه الكبرى يعني
التي يعيشها النظام اذا ما استجاب
للمواطنين كيف يضمن ان لا يطالبون اكثر
فاكثر وبالتالي تنهارته وهم يطالبون
بازاله الحجاب والحجاب هو رمز الثوره
الاسلاميه اذا ما قبل ذلك ان ذلك مشكله
لذلك نرى تناقد لناخذ مثلا يعني منتظر
يقال اننا اوقفنا الشرطه الاخلاقيه حسين
جلال قال ان هناك خطه جديده وهي تقوم على
ان اا يعني يتعرفون على المراه المخالفه
من خلال التكنولوجيا التي تتعرف على
الوجوه ثم يرسلون تحذيرا لها عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي واذا لم تستجب لذلك
يمنعوها من الاشتراك في البنك وفي امور
اخرى داخل البلاد اذا النظام يفكر باليات
جديده للقناه من جهه ويتشدد من جهه اخرى
والغرب همم اضافه لما ذكرته فيما يتعلق
بدعم المتظاهرين يقوم بفرض همم عقوبات
مختلفه على ايران هل استخدم كل اوراق وما
هي الورقه التي يمكن لها بالفعل ان تؤثر
على الداخل الايراني
يعني لا يوجد لدى الغرب الا الا عمليه وهو
ان يضغط يعني عسكريا بمعنى يعني التدخل
الفعلي في دعم المتظاهرين
والضغط الحقيقي على ايران حتى الان الغرب
يقوم بعقوبات اقتصاديه لا غايب ويقوم
بتصريحات ووضع عقوبات على اطراف الحرس
الثوري وهذا لم يؤثر عليهم على الاطلاق
طبعا الاقتصاد اثر وهو احد الاسباب التي
ادت ايضا الى هذه الثوره لكن عندما تشعر
ايران ان الغرب بدا عمليا يفكر في الضغط
عليها عسكريا ويدعم
الفصائل المعارضه الداخليه فان الايراني
السلطه الايرانيه ستغير ستتحاول ان تعدل
نوعا من مصاريا
استاذ القانون الدولي والباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى العراق ركود المياه والجفاف الذي
تشهده محافظه النجف الواقعه في الجنوب
الغربي للعاصمه بغداد تسبب في انتشار
الامراض الفتاكه التي ساهمت في انخفاض
الانتاج السمكه وتراجع واحده من اكثر
المهن علاقه في البلاد نشاهد التفاصيل
منذ سنوات والعراق يعاني من انخفاض
المتواصل في الايرادات المائيه عبر نهري
دجله والفرات وتحديدا في محافظه النجف
الواقعه في الجنوب الغربي للعاصمه بغداد
المحافظه التي كانت تعرف لدى الجميع بانها
المنطقه الغنيه بالمياه والتي كان بامكان
سكانها الوصول الى المياه العذبه من
الابار للحفاظ على الثروه السمكيه
اما الان فقد انعكس الوضع تماما
وتسبب ركود المياه والجفاف فيها الى
انتشار الامراض الفتاكه التي ساهمت في
انخفاض الانتاج السمكيه
بصراحه
يعني زادت الامراض علينا من زادت الامراض
الاسماك تمرضت يعني
فانتاجيت قلت شوف ان كانت الانهار شويه
ميه مرتفع ومجاري مثل ما نقول احنا نعبر
عليه يعني كان وصلنا مي عزب بالابار
مالتنا كان نقدر نستفاد من الماء
شوي شوي قام يصعد الكبريت عدنا بالماء
ماله البيض وهذا سببها لاكات
السبب الرئيسي ويعود الى انخفاض التدفقات
من ايران وتركيا والتي كانت تصدر حوالي
70% من نهرين دجله والفرات واصبح الجفاف
والعواصف الرمليه ودرجات الحراره العاليه
تشكل تهديدا وجودا لدى العراقيين بشكل
متزايد
فانتاج الاسماك في محافظه النجف قد بلغ
نحو الكيط من سنويا في عام 2018
وانخفض حاليا الى نحو 700 طن وفقا لمدير
زراعه في النجف وهو الامر الذي ادى بطبيعه
الحال الى نقص الاسماك في السوق وارتفاع
اسعارها بشكل مبالغ وتوقف بعض المزارعين
عن العمل
20 20 طن او 40 طن
سعر الدولار ماكو ما يسدد حتى
شعر الاسماك اللي تجيبه فاحنا
بالله قلت من اقل الانتاج توقفنا عن العمل
وقد احتجت بغداد مرارا على هذه السدود
المشيد على نهري الفرات ودجله التي يعتمد
عليها العراق في تامين المياه كما فاطمه
ازمه شح المياه تدني كميات الامطار على
مدى السنوات الماضيه بسبب التغير المناخي
سلطان العبان العربيه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
العالم يترقب والطرفه الثاني لنهائي
المونديال موقعه ساخنه بين المغرب مفاجاه
البطوله وفرنسا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه مع دخول اضراب
عمال السكك الحديديه في بريطانيا يومه
الثاني انضم لهم اليوم عمال البريد
مطالبين بتحسين الاجور وشروط العمل
الاضراب اوقف العمل باكثر من نصف الخطوط
الحديديه كما توقفت بشكل تام في اسكتلندا
وويلز ايضا قطاع التمريض دخل على خط
الاضرار بالتوقف عن العمل في المشافي
والمؤسسات التابعه لخدمه الصحه الوطنيه من
الواحد والعشرين من ديسمبر للمطالبه
بزياده الاجور بنسبه 19% فيما تحاول
الحكومه البريطانيه مواجهه هذه التحديات
بعقد اجتماعات طارئه بهدف التخفيف من
تدعيات الاضرابات خاصه بالتزامن مع فتره
الاعياد في المملكه المتحده
الرياضه المغرب يشرق في المونديال ربما
كانت تاهل المنتخب بدايات الحلم الا انه
استمر ليصبح واقعا وبالرغم من ان المواجهه
الاولى انتهت بالتعادل مع كرواتيا الا ان
منتخب المغرب استطاع ان يتفوق على كندا
بهدفين مقابل واحد متاهلا لدوري السته عشر
رقصه فلامنجو جميله هكذا كان مشهد
المباراه بين المغرب واسبانيا عدا ان اسود
الاطلس تفوقوا على اصحاب الفلامنجو في
رقصتهم وانتقلوا الى جارتها البرتغال
ليخطف الفوز بهدف نظيف الفرحه وايضا الفخر
لم ترتسم فقط في وجوه امهات اللاعبين بل
ان عكست في شوارع مدن عديده حول العالم في
الرباط والدار البيضاء في الدوحه وحتى
باريس فرحه هي الاولى في التاريخ هو
المنتخب عربي وافريقيا تاهل الى نصف
النهائي مجهود وامل سعى اليه اسود الاطلس
في مواجهه عمالقه الساحره المستديره خطوه
واحده تفصل رابع اقوى منتخب على مستوى
العالم لانتزاع المرتبه الثانيه تخطوها مع
الديك الفرنسي اليوم باتجاه الكاس الاغلى
في العالم على كل المزيد معنا من الدوحه
مو فادي العربيه ليس بازاري اهلا بك ليث
نقول لنا الاجواء من عندك
26 دقيقه تفصلنا عن المباراه التي ستقام
بين المنتخب المغربي والمنتخب الفرنسي هنا
في البيت بيت الشعر وهو اكبر بيت شعر هنا
في قطر طبعا
86,000 68,000
و895
وكما تشاهدين نحن نبعد قليلا عن استاذ لان
الامن والحراسه لوصول للرئيس الفرنسي الى
استاد ستكون مشدده
علينا ان نقف السياره هنا ومن ثم نترجل
نحو استاد استاد البيت او البيت الشعر همم
الذي نشاهد في الصوره وبعد ذلك طبعا ست-
يعني ستكون الحراسه همم اكيد اكثر بكثير
من الملاعب التي شاهدنا قبل قبل ذلك
العاصمه الدوحه ساعود الى همم
هل من شخصيات رسميه معروف ستاتي ام انه
همم العنوان الرئيسي هي امهات اللاعبين
حتى هذه اللحظه ولا ندري من سياتي ولكن
طبعا من الشخصيات المغربيه اتكلم ولكن هنا
يعني اذا شاهدنا في الصوره هذا الملعب سوف
تكون حراسه مشدده مره اخرى واشدد على هذه
النقطه وعلينا ان نترجل من هنا من المكان
موقف السيارات الى هناك مسافه تقريبا نصف
ساعه مشا على الاقدام حتى نصل ملعب البيت
وهذا الملعب الذي يقع شمال الدوحه في
منطقه سميسمه يقع تقريبا 35 دقيقه عن وسط
الدوحه فهذا طبعا سيكون يعني حافزا لان
يشاهد الحافلات التي وصلت من النصف او من
منطقه همم مشارب وسوق واقف التي تحمل
الكثير من المشجعين لم يشاهد حتى هذه
اللحظه الكثير من المشجعين الفرنسيين ولكن
شهدنا المغاربه والالوان الاحمر والاخضر
التي تقصد لوحه الكثير منهم حضروا من
مناطق مختلفه ليس فقط من المغرب شاهدنا من
السويد من فرنسا من مناطق بلدان اخرى وحتى
البعض منهم مقيم هنا في في قطر اتوا
تخصيصا لمشاهده هذه المباراه وتشجيع
المنتخب المغربي
حذرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من تفكيك قيود
الصين تجاه فيروس كورونا منظمه الصحه حذرت
من اوقات عصيبه ستمر بها الصين بالتزامن
مع الابلاغ عن حالات خطيره في مشاكل بكين
ما زاد من الخوف من موجه اصابات المتحدثه
باسم الصحه العالميه قالت انه من الصعب
دائما على اي بلد ان يخرج من وضع فيه
ضوابط صارمه الصين كانت اعلنت الاربعاء
الماضي عن تغيير في قواعد الاختبار والحجر
الصحي مخففه من القيود الصارمه
خسائر في القروض تصاب بها بعض المصارف
التي اقرضت الام ماسك الملياردير الامريكي
مليار دولار لشراء تويتر حيث تتبع المصارف
اليه بيع القروض للمستثمرين الا انه في
حاله التويتر ستصل للخسائر الى المليارات
اذا تم اتباعه تلك الاليه اذ لن يقوم
المستثمرون بشراء القروض في الوضع الحالي
الحساس للطائر الازرق بعد ان توقف
المعلنون عن الاعلان على المنصه لم تحدد
المصارف القيمه السوقيه للقروض بعد لكن
يمكنها ان تقرر مقدارها بناء على تقديرات
السوق
في الولايات المتحده دمرت عاصفه شتويه
العديد من المباني في اوكلاهوما وتكساس
كما تسببت بعدد من الحوادث المروريه فضلا
عن الغاء اكثر من 70 رحله جويه هذا وكانت
هيئه الارصاد الجويه الوطنيه حذرت من
احتمال حدوث فيضانات مفاجاه في هذه
الولايات المتابعه
[موسيقى]
الخامس شكرا متابعه مشاهدينا